actually it was quite an easy decision
in the end it was Daniel Craig who watch
me too at a party that said I said who's
directing the next bomb move in he said
I don't know do you want to do it and I
thought actually yes and then the more I
thought about it over the next couple of
weeks the better idea it's seen and so
in the end yeah it was it offered me a
whole series of new challenges you know
I'd never done action before I wanted to
go back to England to make a movie I've
made five American movies and I'm wishes
in probably here and I wanted to work
with Daniel again and work with him on
road to perdition ten years ago I
wondered what would you do Dench again
who have worked with on stage and I
wanted to work on this kind of scale and
bond like all of my generation is part
of my you know it's part of my histories
but my family's history and I felt I had
maybe something I could say about it so
so in the end it wasn't a difficult
decision
I can talk about working the entire car
so I'll be here a very long time but and
what it meant to me I mean they're great
actors I mean I have asked for the you
know it's a very unusual situation to
have that every single person I offered
a role to say yes first choice you know
so from ray Fiennes to have your bottom
to bend wish or two naomie harris they
were all the first trips and I felt
unbelievably you know lucky to have
everyone working on on a movie like this
well I won't be specific about cameras
except to say the one camera the camera
we use on this the Alexa was was
magnificent I have I think the image is
extraordinary I think the way of working
on digital is sometimes better and
sometimes not as good as in film there
are certain things I miss about film I
miss some of the softness of film to
clean clothes up I think it's kinder on
human skin but it requires much more
light and you know you can work much
quicker with digital cameras as a
consequence and I I i missed the dailies
the ritual of dailies which you have on
film much more than you do on on digital
but in every other respect I think that
the Alexa is an extraordinary
groundbreaking camera